hold on before we begin this video
there's something really important we
need you to do just remember this phrase
while you're watching it's crucial that
you don't let these four words slip out
of your head even for a split second you
can even pause the video and repeat the
sentence to yourself a few times just to
get it to fully sink in remember please
belief is the key we have all wondered
at one point or another what happens
after after our lives draw to their
inevitable clothes and we take our last
breath in the land of the living what
happens to us it's a question that has
baffled scientists and philosophers all
over the world for almost as long as
human civilization has existed what
happens after we die well the answer to
that particular question normally varies
depending on who you choose to ask there
are as you probably already know
numerous beliefs held by all religions
and cultures around the globe that their
exists and afterlife while the
description of the afterlife is often
dependent on the religious or cultural
group it is linked to the concept
usually revolves around the soul leaving
the body after death and living forever
in eternal paradise that is of course
unless you've committed sin during your
lifetime which normally results in being
sent down to spend eternity in
punishment instead of paradise but sadly
there's no way to prove which if any of
the various afterlifes actually exist by
their very nature these afterlifes exist
separate from the real physical world
that we live in while we are still alive
stuck here on earth we can only observe
what we see happening after death and
what we assume it might be like after
all it's not like a dead person can tell
us what being dead is like well under
usual circumstances anyway with no proof
of the afterlife's existence we do
unfortunately get left with the bleak
and existentially horrifying assumption
that when we die there is nothing
waiting for us on the other side no
light at the end of the tunnel no pearly
gates just
nothing forever of course being
unconscious for eternity isn't quite as
bad as the other possibility what could
that other possibility be
well according to the scp foundation's
entry for scp-2718
you might not want to know anyone
attempting to access the data file on
scp-2718 will immediately notice a few
details that set it apart from others
contained in the foundation's archive
firstly an ever-changing scp number it
perpetually swaps numbers with other
files to keep itself hidden next a
unique object class that is only found
in this entry instead of ketter or
euclid or safe class that you might
expect you'll read demeron a german word
that loosely translates to either dusk
dawn twilight or nightfall you might
also spot the anomaly special
containment procedures mentioning that
this page of the scp database has been
specially constructed in such a way that
makes it as difficult as possible to
access the entry itself even begs the
person reading it not to go any further
not to look at the description of
scp-2718
now we all know that the foundation goes
to great lengths to keep some things a
secret but why all the added measures
for scp-2718
it might well be that the information
contained behind all this extra security
could change the lives of anyone that
reads it or to put it more accurately it
could change the afterlives of whoever
learns what scp-2718
really is this anomaly isn't a
nightmarish creature or an object with a
strange function it's not an entity from
outside our universe or even a person
with an unusual origin
scp-2718 is a cognito hazard a piece of
information that poses a direct danger
to anyone that is able to understand it
that's why the foundation has so many
pleas to not read it any further they're
not doing that to protect the
organization and their secrets but to
try and protect the reader themselves
all personnel regardless of clearance
are forbidden to expose themselves to
the description of this article under
any circumstances do not discuss the
existence of this article with any
person no disciplinary action will be
necessary provided you close this
article now and clear your browser cache
sounds serious right so serious in fact
that anyone trying to learn about
scp-2718
is actively discouraged to do so even
members of foundation personnel are
offered exemption from punishment if
they just do what they're told and turn
away but you still want to know don't
you alright don't say we didn't try our
best to warn you you've ignored all the
signs the repeated warnings to not look
any further into scp-2718
to not look at its description or pass
that information on to anyone else no
you just had to keep digging deeper and
deeper didn't you searching for the
answers you're going to wish you never
had gone looking for in the first place
bush far enough through the security
measures the foundation is placed around
the scp-2718
file and you'll find a transcribed audio
recording from none other than a member
of the 05 council the councilwoman
miriam prather 05-7 speaks to a
subordinate who begins the recording as
it starts she talks about how the
various members of the o5 council have
used various anomalous means and
sometimes other scps to artificially
extend their lifespans the council is
functionally immortal boring right
anyone who knows enough about the scp
foundation already knows that functional
immortality is what has kept the o5s in
power for so many decades but what you
might not know is that there was one
council member who didn't his name was
roger sheldon despite being offered each
of the 19 known methods of extending
life that the other overseers have
gladly used sheldon refused each and
every one instead he would often go on
vacations away from the foundation
without announcing his intention to do
so both doing this and refusing to
become immortal in some ways are actions
that are now forbidden for any member of
the o5 council presumably because of
roger on one of his impromptu trips away
roger sheldon died from a stroke given
that he didn't let anyone know where he
was planning on going he was sadly left
to rot after his death however roger
possessed an important anomalous
artifact in his possession at all times
meaning that the scp foundation was keen
to recover his body and by extension
this object he also had knowledge of a
unique keyword a phrase referred to as a
shibboleth which the other overseers
needed to extract from sheldon but how
do you get information from a dead man
well you bring him back to life of
course and we're not talking about the
normal kind of resurrection the
foundation often indulges in which is
really just glorified cloning this is
the ripping of an actual soul back from
the void and placing it inside its body
once more so it can live again as it
once did eventually after 14 years of
searching roger sheldon's remains were
exhumed and then returned to the
foundation there his personal belongings
were recovered including the mysterious
artifact then just as planned they
revived roger in order to recover the
shibboleth from his memory the o5
council had commissioned the creation of
a brand new body for roger one that
perfectly matched his old one in every
conceivable detail and it worked what
was odd was that the formerly deceased
overseer who had refused to extend his
lifespan and live forever seemed
overjoyed to be brought back from the
dead the resurrection seemed to work
exactly as intended even better in fact
with roger now firmly back among the
living he appeared to have a newfound
interest in preserving human life and
empathy for others that he'd never shown
before sheldon was concerned about
personnel safety and containment
protocols in a way he hadn't been before
his stroke but this apparent compassion
was underscored by something else
caution roger never went anywhere
without an entourage of medical staff
and bodyguards almost frightened of how
fragile life was you might think there's
nothing too alarming about this behavior
that maybe death had given sheldon a new
perspective an appreciation for the
delicate nature of human life but it was
more than that it was an unprecedented
fear a phobia of allowing people anyone
to die
then came roger sheldon's most
unpredictable course of action acting
against all regulations and foundation
protocols he secretly rushed into the
containment chamber of scp-106
this anomaly is a humanoid that secretes
a black goop from its body capable of
dragging human beings into a pocket
dimension that it controls and uses to
torture its victims sheldon was trying
to make some kind of bargain with
scp-106 when he was detained by miriam
prather when told to explain his actions
roger sheldon eventually gave them his
horrifying testimony the reason he'd
been so afraid and so cautious after his
resurrection he knew what happened after
death cast your mind back to the start
of this video all that talk about
afterlives and what really happens to us
after we die well there is one answer to
that question that doesn't often cross
people's minds in fact everyone who
ponders the question what happens after
subconsciously tries to overlook it
because to even think it's possible
presents a whole horde of horrors in
itself what could be such a terrifying
thought that we all hope it simply isn't
true it's the simple horrible
possibility that has hardly occurred to
anyone throughout human history that the
dead remain conscious after their bodies
have shut down
they remain aware of everything that
happens to them
they are able to feel themselves slowly
decaying bones and skin withering away
buried under the cold wasting away into
nothingness day after day
that is what scp-2718
is after suffering his stroke roger
sheldon explained how he could still
feel everything happening to him skin
blistered and split in the sunlight
fighting insects descended rapidly i
felt eggs hatch larvae crawl gases build
and burst within me individual cells
rupturing intersteel fluids showering
and blackening somehow my capacity to
experience and store these sensations
grew i was aware of every fingernail and
strand of hair that pulled away in the
wind he went on describing every horror
he'd experienced in lurid detail as his
body broke down in real time knowing
that those same images and thoughts
would never leave his head shocked by
the revelation miriam and the other
overseer rushed to hold a meeting of the
rest of the o5 council wherein roger
once again described his posthumous
experience hearing what happens after
death drove every council member mad
each reacting with shock stress and
anger one of them tried to calm the rest
down while another motion to treat death
itself as a ketter class scp and
neutralize it the chaos was eventually
quelled when 05-1 silenced the other o5s
activating emergency protocol 17 to gas
the overseers with amnestics to wipe
their memories of what they had learned
only roger and dash 7 were able to
escape the room before the bulkhead
sealed and the gas was deployed roger
believed that people had a right to know
about scp-2718
agreeing with him miriam created a log
of all she knew about what happens after
death then permanently locking it within
the scp database protected from ever
being deleted or having its description
altered however on the orders of 05-1
miriam was gunned down by foundation
personnel leaving roger to escape
presumably he returned to scp-106
agreeing to be tortured forever in the
creature's pocket dimension to him that
was preferable to dying so if you now
know what
scp-2718 is then why did we start this
video with the phrase belief is the key
well as we said earlier this anomaly is
a cognito hazard it's a phenomenon that
only occurs after you are exposed to a
certain piece of information that
knowledge is what's being contained here
within the entry left by 05-7 you see
it's actually knowing what happens to
you after death that makes scp-2718
happen if you spend your life believing
in a version of the afterlife only to
then learn about scp-2718
then that information will override
whatever religion culture or faith led
you to believe about death knowing about
scp-2718 overwrites your afterlife it
creates a new endless and meaningless
pain as you experience every sensation
beyond your death decay decomposition
cremation that's the reason that belief
is the key because once you are exposed
to it as cp 2718 becomes what happens
after you die in our defense we warned
you now go check out scp-2935
oh death and scp-657 death predicting
man for more anomalies about death the
true final frontier